[Music]
you mentioned cheryl earlier i'd like to
come back to cheryl so this is a
question from a female friend of mine
i'll just read it kind of as it's as
it's written and i'd love to to hear
your thoughts so mark's business
partnership with cheryl is legendary i
can't off the top of my head think of
another partnership like this male
female lasted 15 or so years 15 plus
still going
why does it work how does it work why
does he think so very few others have
such a partnership and
i'll just add one more you know what has
shifted in his life and business as a
result so i'd just love to hear any any
thoughts on that because it does strike
me also as
a very
unusual
partnership that has been
that has proven itself within tremendous
longevity yeah i mean i think in a lot
of ways
that partnership has defined the growth
of the company and and so first of all i
would give a huge amount of credit for
this working to cheryl i think she is an
amazing person and if you think about
where
you know when when she joined the
company
i was like a kid
right i mean it's um she was actually as
old as i am now almost 15 years ago and
and you know i was in my early 20s and
and didn't know anything about
about about business or running a
company or anything like this and i just
think the the kind of extraordinary
amount of patience that she had and i
mean in a way is like as a
manager of an organization it's almost
like she raised me like a child and not
just me i think like a lot of the people
we have on the on the team now
so i mean so i think she's she's
exceptional in that way
one thing that's interesting about our
company
is that the business is sort of oddly
divorced from the actual product right
so most things it's like okay you build
a product and you sell the product and
in our case i think one of the things
that created enough space for someone
who has as much energy and and as a
senior as cheryl to join is the fact
that in in the type of business that we
have
the consumer part of what we do
is actually somewhat distinct from the
advertising the business part of what we
do so you know there was there was
enough space i think in the company to
have
to have two people right who basically
were like primary principles for the
company and you know i've i've debated
this with a bunch of other peers and
people who've created companies i mean i
know i i
you you had a great podcast with daniel
eck a while ago towards the beginning of
covet and now i've had this discussion
with him a bunch of times he's like i
just couldn't do that right it's like
because he says like literally for for
spotify it's like they they build the
the business and the content and all
that stuff is like part of that's like
one kind of package whereas i think
we're sort of uniquely set up where we
can
i can focus on the consumer part of what
we do and she can focus on all the
advertising and building the business
and that just has worked incredibly well
over over a long period of time and and
i think will for for for a long time to
come so i just have a huge amount to
learn from her and i think she probably
feels i i guess she feels the same way
but you'd have to ask her
yeah maybe that'll be round two yeah so
i do think that you know the separation
of church and state i mean that's
probably an overstatement but the the
clearly delineated halves of the company
so to speak
lend themselves to that it's a really
good point what are her
super powers i know that may be a
strange word to use but i think of say
warren buffett referring to charlie
munger and saying he is the best
60-second mind on the planet right they
have very complementary skill sets
slightly different views of the world
although
highly compatible values
what are cheryl's
superpowers that come to mind if any
well i think she has a very good
combination
of
like iq and eq people either i think
tend to be more manager or more
strategic and i think she is
very unique in being both and i just
think that that's pretty rare right and
obviously if you get if you get someone
who's great at strategy or graded
products and they're not a great manager
that's great right it's like i mean if
you can have someone who's excellent at
one of those things it's like you hire
them every day right so i think it's
just exceptionally rare to find people
who are kind of
spike in both of those areas
i think about this in terms of
she actually uses a lot of dating
analogies i don't but i was talking to a
friend who was single recently and we
were talking about why she was single
and i do just think like some people
want to go through life with
partnerships more than others yeah i
think that there are some people who
like want a co-founder they want a
partner who they can run the thing with
and who can kind of have they can have
that experience with on a day-to-day
basis and then there are other people
who are just like okay
like no i'll just i'll just have a team
of like you know five or six people
around me and like i'll i'll kind of be
the the leader the founder but you know
i don't need like a another you know
person and i just think that's that's
different
partnership has always meant a lot to me
both in my my personal life and and in
work i like i like want people to be on
the voyage with me right it's like this
isn't like a solo story that's like a
lot of how i derive meaning in in life
and again you'd have to ask her whether
she maybe she's oriented in a similar
way but i think to some degree i think
whether partnerships work over time
probably the number one factor in that
is whether you want the partnership to
work
yes for sure or if out of the box in a
sense you are predisposed to partnership
yeah
you